[Music]
oh damn
check that it
out what
is
that
i didn't know they made them like that
i don't even understand what i'm seeing
i would love to see what's under there i
am really curious about that
yeah dog yeah
i mean i have no idea
well you know we uh we obviously have
some idea you know
i don't
well you know it's uh you know it's a
coochie baby
yeah
or something
ah no no nah man it's it's definitely
her lady parts
or
maybe it's just more skin
no
it's a vagina yeah
or
maybe it's a little face under there
uh no no it's it's definitely gonna be a
vagina
why
but because she's a girl and girls have
vaginas man
what is that
what is a vagina
it's a woman's reproductive organ what
are you being serious right now
thank you
that is all i require
this aliens
there's an alien down here
[Applause]
[Music]
for so
long i didn't feel so right baby how
could this feeling be wrong
[Applause]
sometimes the thing that you've been
searching for
has been right there the whole time
so baby i'm here to tell ya i'm waiting
right here just to make you all mine
you're the one i always hope for
it's a feeling i can't
[Music]
and i hide been here baby standing right
here by your side
[Applause]
yes
been building up inside of me
and i just gotta come out
[Music]
and tell you what i'm feeling girl tell
you all love is what i'm talking about
i
gotta tell you what my heart knows
and what it has known for so long
i finally need to show you my eyes are
wide open that's where you belong
you know i make love to your journey
i've seen it in my mind
i will take care of you baby
baby let's take our sweet time do it
till you slow the way you've never done
before we're open up your mind i will
open up your door i've been searching
all around over what i
sometimes the thing you're searching for
has been there the whole time
i want to give you all i got now
and i'll take all you can get you
and i'll never turn my back on you as
long as we both shall leave i'm talking
about you
you standing right in front of you
nothing left to hide you sugar say i'm
telling you everything i've kept very
deep inside
i'm rubbing up against your big bald
head your big bald head i'll shed your
big bald head in the knot there's no one
else i could be possibly talking about
cause you are bald and you are here
[Music]
you
you're a woman i'm a man now you
and you know that's how i like it
and i'm specifically talking about you
because you're a girl and i am the
opposite
woman woman woman woman woman
you are a woman i am a man
you know i like women
have you ever found yourself in high
porn north carolina and nothing unsafe
come on down to doug duggar's brazilian
jiu jitsu
you will learn to tackle on grappler
like an ultimate fighting pro
in my studio you get hands-on training
and individual attention
tackle and grapple
take on multiple enemies this is a tap
that's a grapple right there
this is a tackle
that's a grapple
there we are
[Music]
raffle all ages learn to protect
yourself and your loved ones
tackling rapping
there are many different levels there's
the beginning level and if you pass my
private one-on-one sensei trial
you may make it into the advanced class
tackle rapper the duggars brazilian jiu
jitsu at the high point mini mall just
east of the pizza barn two doors down
from kyle's discount reels and furniture
quick tackle get there
uh trip him
there
sit wait no stakes stay away
special discounts for college students
this
what's the matter rich in the next
episode steve urkel turns carl into a
giant sandwich and accidentally eats him
oh wait that's hilarious but it's
hilarious come on i'm an actor gene this
was supposed to be about me and my
family no but you know after that after
that first death spot with steve urkel i
mean america fell in love with him man
we had to make him a regular and you
know hey listen he's the star of the
show now sweetheart we gotta play ball
bubba don't you dare bubble a me gene
now last week steve used his
transformation machine to turn carl into
a car and drive him around the monaco
grand prix come on how many times are we
going to use this transformation machine
this was supposed to be a blue collar
cosby show now you turn it into goddamn
quantum leap who writes
i i couldn't tell you even if i wanted
to okay maybe we got like 21 writers up
there okay you know what i'm saying
reginald but you and i both know that
they don't decide what happens in the
show okay we both know who decides what
happens in the show two weeks ago steve
urkel used his invisibility ray on carl
and i wasn't even in the goddamn episode
it was just my voice yes i know i know
richard i'm sorry i apologize we'll
never happen again then steve used his
voice changing ray to turn carl into a
high-pitched nerdy voice who do you
think provided the voice for that don't
get too feisty on me now reg let's not
go down that path okay oh oh we're going
down that path gene in a couple of weeks
harriet eddie laura grandma on rachel
little richie and the other little kid
are gonna get teleported to another
dimension and then steve injects carl
with his own dna so carl turns into
another steve urkel that's two steve
urkels and no family on a show called
family matters how the does that work
listen listen french i don't want to
tell you erko mania is unstoppable okay
he's a phenomenon there's nothing we can
do about okay it's up to
him no no no no no i'm an actor i'm a
factor i am a real actor i need richard
the third i was in true west with
sherman helmsley i was in die hard damn
it
steve urkel
you will suck steve urkels if he wants
you to you will suck
you understand he has our bread and
butter you mother
i am high on cocaine i'm a master gene
i've done more cocaine than you weigh
mother i'm going to tell you what you
are wrestling johnson you're a
pawn in that nerd's game
you are a
pawn do you think i have any power over
what that monster does any power at all
i am the senior
vice president of development for the
american bro
jane
gene
gene what's become of eugene
[Music]
i
am nothing
do you not i don't know what you mean by
that to you but you're scaring me no no
don't don't do anything crazy gene
everyone does too much coke sometimes
but just what are you gonna do with the
gun gene what are you gonna do no no no
no no no
we can talk this through
uh okay
the king is dead
long live the king
did i do that
[Music]
jaleel jamil
there is no jalil
only steve
it's always been steve
give me guys
forgetting something carl
don't you come near me stay away from me
here could have all been so simple carl
just say your lines
and take the money your monster
what are you doing
i i
i can't control
am i doing this
no no no no no no no no see ah i'll do
anything you will do what i want on
family matters
[Music]
see you on set carl
get out of my house steve
[Music]
oh
huh did you hear that
[Music]
must have been nothing
back patio is clear
[Music]
so
uh
nice
[Music]
now it's my turn to play
oh
[Music]
carol
i thought i killed you the first time mr
t
i promise
i will not make the same mistake twice
[Music]
you are a good cop mr chili
but a lousy fighter
[Music]
oh
snap indeed
[Music]
teague
you saved my life no carol
you saved mine
[Music]
oh
that's just
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]